i was wrongly convicted of murder and
sentenced to life
imprisonment plus 54 years with no
[Music]
parole
[Music]
the night of the 15th and 16th of
december 1988
three men set out on a series of
robberies
and during the commission of one of
these robberies an
old man died from a heart attack having
been detained
by the perpetrators so three crimes
in one night involving three
perpetrators
a murder two aggravated robberies
and an attempted murder there was a huge
reward
offered for the arrest of the men
involved in what became known
as the m25 crimes two days after that
murder and robberies the police
came to my flat kicked off my flat door
with guns pointing at me and they
arrested me
they took me to a police station
where i was interrogated for three days
all of a sudden i'm sitting in front of
two very senior police officers
good cop bad cop and they were throwing
accusation after accusation
accusing me of doing things of being
places of having things that i just
didn't have
so although that was terrifying there
was a
an element of but i didn't do that i
wasn't there
that didn't belong to me so i could
answer back because i was confident
although terrified although angry
although young i was still
capable of standing up to the police
because i knew the
truth and the truth was i wasn't
involved in what they were accusing me
of
i wouldn't say that we were used as a
scapegoat
what i would say is that we were fitted
into a crime
once the police had already reached a
decision
that they needed a conviction myself my
co-defendant and most of the other
residents of the house that i was living
in
had had brushes with the law some were
there on probation
some like myself had previous
convictions for for minor offenses
burglary shoplifting but that's as
serious as it got
the evidence the police said they had at
the time had come from
witnesses one of those descriptions was
that
the main perpetrator was white had blue
eyes
and fair hair the two black men me and
my co-defendant who had dreadlocks have
brown eyes
the other co-defendant was an african
guy so he had even darker skin and short
black hair when the police discovered
the car that was found at the scene of
the murder
and carried out forensic examinations of
that car
they discovered fingerprints were found
on that car
the fingerprints didn't fit me or the
two other men that were already charged
with the offences
they fitted one individual and that
individual
became the key witness in my case he
incidentally was white had blue eyes
and fair hair he was the only one in the
whole case
who fitted the description of the
perpetrator
described by the victims when the police
discovered those fingerprints on the car
at the scene of the murder they didn't
go back to that individual and then
treat him as a suspect they then
conspired with that witness
to say that he pushed the car for
me and my co-defendants so as the
evidence
started to point in a different
direction rather than the police follow
the fact of that evidence
they then started to fit us in and that
happened on numerous occasions with
numerous
bits of the evidence that i could go on
and on and on about
and then they proceeded to charge me
with the murder and robberies
on the 22nd of december so that was
three days after i was arrested
and even then when i was charged i
didn't believe i was charged
even when they put me in the sweat box
the little
van with very little windows and little
cubicle that transported me to brixton
prison
that same day while i was in that cell
in brixton prison
and my lawyers would visit me they would
bring me the documentation and i would
then start to see for the very first
time
where the evidence had come from that
led the police
to arrest and charge me so when we
arrived at the
old bailey for the beginning of my trial
i did feel confident i did feel
confident that the jury
would find us not guilty
but the moment came when i was brought
back up into the court
i was sat in the dock and the jury
foreman came in and i knew
they were going to find me guilty when
none of the jury looked at us and smiled
or showed any sign
that they were on our side when the
judge
announced the sentence he could only
give one
for the conviction of murder and that
was a mandatory life sentence
and that simply means that you go to
prison for the rest of your life
and i reacted in the only way an
innocent person
would i screamed and i shouted
at the jury at the court i was 21 years
old now
and i swore and i frothed at the mouth
until i was dragged out of the dock
and back down into the the gulag of the
the old bailey
cells and i wanted to cry
i wanted to cry at that moment but i
didn't
i couldn't take it day by day because
those days just blurred
into one because i couldn't believe what
was happening to me
it was so so difficult going out and
having that first visit with my family
my mother the person who gave birth to
me who now
had to sit and look at a young boy or a
young man
convicted of a murder that i tried to
convince my family and friends i hadn't
committed
and they believed me but everybody would
have that that shadow of doubt
i became a volatile angry young man
every time the prison officers came to
my cell door
to open it and take me out they had to
stand back
because i came out like a raging ball
but i was deeply
angry not for a day or a week or a month
but for years it festered inside me and
it
scarred me to this day people knew who i
was they knew i was fighting some people
supported me most of them thought yeah
you're just another one saying you're
wrongly convicted in a couple of years
you'll accept your guilt and move on
that was never going to happen but i
remember on on one occasion
i met with a guy called richard mckenney
billy power they were convicted of a
notorious miscarriage of justice called
the birmingham six
iraq they were mature they were
approaching it from a campaigning point
of view and i was fighting physically i
was suffering
as a result mentally and physically
but it was during one of the
conversations i had with these guys that
they said you can't do it like that
you're not going to fight your wrongful
conviction if you are innocent
you need to campaign and you need to do
it by winning over the media
you need to do it by telling people on
the outside and trying to get
journalists interested in telling your
story
there was a bit of me that thought no
you're still [ __ ] here and you've got
nowhere
but it wasn't long before i was watching
those guys walk out of the court of
appeal because they'd won their
conviction one by one
years went by the campaign my volatile
bitter angerness was still in me but the
campaign had changed
people outside were starting to support
me i won over the media who were now
writing stories about the potential
miscarriage of justice
and eventually that the tide turned
the european court of human rights
declared
that we had been denied the right to a
fair trial that
information evidence had never been
disclosed to our defense
luckily for me the bbc rough justice
program made a documentary where they
secretly filmed an interview with this
key
blue eye fair hair white guy who
admitted on camera
during a secret recording that he was
paid money by the police and that he
conspired with the police
and just as that was going on the home
secretary
intervened and he had promised to make a
decision about referring my case back to
the court of appeal
and then re-nagged and i went on hunger
strike
and i was on my death bed when um
the criminal case review commission
having been forced by the european court
made a decision to refer my case back to
the court of appeals so i was in
hospital
i was in a bed i'd lost lots of weight
it was my last calling
if you like it was my last shout for
justice
and so in july 2000 um
this different raphael row i was no
longer the 20 year old happy-go-lucky
raffle though i was the dead-eye
stone-heart anger and bitter 20-year-old
that i'd become
but also smarter a smarter person a more
resilient person
than i was and the judges quashed
my conviction and they quashed the
conviction
of my two co-defendants
and they said i was free they said i
could go home
wherever home was going to be
i wasn't going back to prison 12 years
after
that night i was charged
i was told i was free and i could go up
and i remember them
opening that front door me stepping out
and my sister who was
a big campaigner for me and my family
was standing there so for the first
time in 12 years i was able to hug
someone and cry
genuinely cry with joy
everybody else around me was crying and
it triggered my crying i wasn't able to
cry for 12 years
that was the first time i shed a tear
property
for my freedom
are you still angry at the jury and the
police
i'm not as angry or as bitter as i was
when i was in prison
i made a conscious decision when i
walked out of court that i was not going
to let it consume the rest of my life
like it had the previous 12 years
no one since my conviction was
quashed has apologized to me and said
sorry
nobody has been arrested or charged with
the crimes that i was wrongly and
convicted for
in fact i think the police and the
courts would to this day still maintain
that they got the right people because
they have to
it was a long time ago now but i don't
forget any second of it
you